[Music]
[Applause]
thank you and uh
welcome to this debate on a key topic of
the moment the rise of china has for
decades been watched from the west with
distrust
now tensions are escalating
in february
china and russia unveiled a pact
announcing a new global order
and endorsing their respective positions
on taiwan and ukraine
days later russia invaded
and just a few weeks ago in response to
biden's commitment to defend taiwan
ji's spokesman
reiterated that taiwan was part of china
and no one should interfere in an
internal matter
the ancient chinese philosopher sun tzu
declared in peace prepare for war
should this be western strategy
and how should the west respond if china
embarks on its own military adventure
or is preparing for war a dangerous
strategy that risks an arms race and an
unimaginably terrible conflict
well with me to address this critical
topic
of the moment we've got a really
remarkable uh panel chris barry runs his
own strategic forecasting company
advising governments companies and uh
banks
and regularly uh takes part as a
broadcaster and commentator and nigel
inkster
is former director of operations and
intelligence for mi6 and his most recent
book the great decoupling china and the
struggle for technological supremacy
explores china u.s tensions and cindy yu
is a china specialist and broadcast
editor at the spectator
and hosts the podcast chinese whispers
so i'm just going to give each of them a
couple of minutes to address the
question and then in the usual way we'll
open it up to a conversation with the
panel and then toward the audience so
let's begin straight away with you chris
thank you hilary
right from the start um i think most of
you familiar with um
the expression in hamlet alas poor
yorick
well most of the public think the next
line is
uh i i knew him well when in fact it's i
knew him horatio
i'm going to tell you that sunz never
said that
um it's one of those things attributed
to sun tzu uh that was never said in
fact it was vegeta's in his epitome
ray militarist who actually said if you
require peace
then you should prepare for war and i'm
afraid that's typical of anybody and
everybody who tries to study china
and does it in translation they pick up
all sorts of things that aren't actually
true and one of the things i hope we can
do today is look at a lens that sees it
through chinese eyes
but also in an objective way in which we
can view
the decisions and actions that china
takes
now i'm going to say something very
simple and that is we are in a two-block
world now
uh it's not a cold war as such it's a
connected but contested world now and
it's contested between two main blocks
one is the eurasian authoritarians which
are china russia and the one they always
forget iran and together they want to
dominate the whole of the what is known
as the world island in geopolitical
terms that's eurasia they consider
europe for example to be a tiny
promontory on the end of their continent
and what they want to do is dominate the
political economic and diplomatic life
of eurasia to the exclusion of the
americans and something i always read in
russia and i speak russian is how both
the chinese and the russians want to
de-americanize the world and its
institutions
on the other hand you've got what i call
the maritime democracies united states
canada parts of europe not all of it
united kingdom obviously japan south
korea australia new zealand and
increasingly because china is a
strategic opponent
india
and this will be i believe the shape of
the world for the next 30 years and
every other country's elites will be
deciding which side of the fence they
want to flop
so for example who do you think vietnam
will follow they're an autocracy okay
but they're terrified of china so
they're likely to go with the maritime
democracies where will saudi arabia go
well saudi arabia is concerned about
iran
and so they might say if we cozy up to
the chinese they'll keep iran off our
backs so a lot of complex things are
going to be happening over the next few
years
my second point is that since the rise
of xi jinping rather than china itself
we've seen an increasingly assertive
china across every sphere and we can go
into the detail later
but i will say to you that the chinese
are very good at looking at history
and saying right where's best practice
then is it the warring state period just
before the christian era is it the
british east india company yes it is
and all sorts of things and what they've
lighted on
is the ming empire of the 15th century
when china's gdp was two and a half
times that the rest of the world and
what that consisted of was a huge trade
and tribute hub
in the indo-pacific
and also routes to europe along the silk
roads that you know which is today the
belt and road initiative and the sea
routes through to africa what we call
now the middle east and beyond and
that's before the europeans got into the
indian ocean and into the asia pacific
and china's
ambition
is to
dominate eurasia that's how it's going
to do it by recreating
the ming empire of the 15th century
and by 2049 it seeks to dominate
everything under heaven that's not me
saying that
it's them saying that but i'll say to
you in conclusion the agenda has been
brought forward and i'll tell you the
reason why later to 2035 it's not 2049
2035 which is why we've had an
acceleration under xi jinping and what's
his philosophy it's lenin's philosophy i
probe with bayonets
if i meet mush
i continue if i meet steel
i'll withdraw
thank you chris
cindy
um very exciting um
i think i agree with largely everything
that chris said and just to i think your
you know
opening question about whether or not we
should be preparing for war right now i
think yes um we should but it depends on
how we do it
because the very act of preparing for
war is an act of or can be an act of
deterrence um no invading force wants to
see a dragged out war and seen as well
on the subject of sun so since who said
that the best wars were quick wars and i
think that's what russia has failed to
do in ukraine obviously and if china
wanted to do that and its um next
flashpoint i guess would be taiwan it
needs to be sure that it can do that
quickly without this long dragged out
war that we've seen in ukraine
where people who look like you people
who speak like you are suffering because
of your actions and i think you know
there's maybe we'll get onto this in a
bit there's an interesting notion about
what that would do to them to the
chinese in in the prc in the people's
republic of china to see taiwanese
people suffering that way so beijing
wants a quick war if it can do that
so how would that war happen if it
happens if um and i defer to chris's
military
expertise on this so dude let me know if
i'm wrong but it happens if the
amphibious landing is successful and
fast something that the russians don't
have to
know
have you seen the terrain no
no but that's this is what i mean if
they can manage that they won't
nobody can the hypothetical if they can
if they can manage that with it requires
a joint uh operation between all three
parts of the people's liberation army
it's a more difficult challenge than
ukraine because that's land invasion it
also happens quickly if there is no
western or american response and also if
the taiwan needs acquiesce now i think
chris is right you know the pla is
actually very bad at doing this kind of
joint operation so a you know that's a
big question mark but that's something
that we in the west can't impact as much
as we can impact bnc which is our
response and how much taiwanese
resist and i think ukraine has actually
been a very interesting case in point on
that because we've seen that through a
lot of western support military
financial
and ukrainian people themselves you know
they have dragged out this war and so if
we can do a similar thing for taiwan in
preparation i think that could be
something that is a helpful thing to
prepare for in peace but i want to
caveat that which is just to say that
you know this this notion of the
security dilemma in international
relations where what one country sees as
defensive is actually offensive to
another country so if you start you know
drawing your attention to the
indo-pacific as it's fashionably known
now
arming taiwan um that will trigger you
know certain lawn belts in beijing and
obviously this is a chicken and egg
problem you know because we in the west
might say well just the chinese being
very aggressive but the chinese will see
western aggression in those actions and
in particular i think
the role of japan is very interesting
here because since ukraine has been talk
of
potentially putting american nuclear
weapons in japan potentially
uh recon
changing the japanese constitution so
that it can be have a stronger military
those kind of actions of course would
change the balance of power in asia but
at the same time japan is a very special
case here so i think
when we talk about army in japan we have
to remember the history that japan still
has in the region so that kind of
preparation for war um is actually i
think could lead to a lot of paranoia
not just in china but also in south
korea where a lot of
japan's war crimes were committed during
during the second world war and
something that japanese politicians to
this day do not properly recognize in
the same way that germany for example
recognizes so if we're going to be
giving nukes to japan if we're going to
be arming the military are we really
sure that that's not actually going to
lead to more paranoia not just in china
but throughout asia in general so i
think
so i would just say you know in all this
preparation diplomacy communication is
very very important and just being
mindful of the regional history and the
baggage that is still very very much you
know open wounds in asia at the moment
thank you cindy nigel yeah um thank you
well i mean you know taiwan for china is
unfinished business from the civil war
that normally ended in 1949
and xi jinping recently declared that in
order to realize the great rejuvenation
of the chinese nation his kind of
signature policy to which chris briefly
alluded um you know it is necessary
first to achieve national reunification
which is get taiwan back
and taiwan has become
um
you know the epicenter of essentially a
contest contestation between the
incumbent hegemon the united states and
the rising power china
um you know i mean people are very
critical of graham allison's uh thick
adidas trap but uh you know he does have
a point um
and you know he is right this is you
know not a new situation for the world
um and where where does china actually
sit on this at the moment well for
for years now you know decades even
pretty much since the first gulf war
we've seen china focusing relentlessly
on military modernization turning from
a pla that is a land-based mass
mobilization
uh force configured to fight a people's
war not project power beyond its borders
to an all-arms um or capability um
uh force uh technologically enabled and
with growing um
capacity for global reach this is the
reality that we're facing you know in
the last few years china has been adding
uh more ships to its fleet than you know
the british navy actually possesses um
and uh we're seeing this kind of arms
race taking place
um
so you know
what what is the likely outcome here
china still wants to recover taiwan
peacefully if it can this remains their
stated policy and you know i think it is
you know i think they still mean it you
know obviously the benefits to them of
peaceful recovery far outweigh having to
to fight their way there
but the simple fact is that taiwan is
slipping away public opinion in taiwan
is moving away from reunification
towards a separate taiwanese identity
exacerbated by recent events in hong
kong so one country two systems is no
longer seen as a credible offer to
to the taiwanese people
um
you know china says that it's red line
is if taiwan declares independence but
what we're seeing at the moment is a
situation in which ev you know since the
trump administration took office the
united states has been
ostentatiously using taiwan as a means
of prodding china it has been a series
of you know
punches to the stomach which in the
short term china has no no real answer
to
um you know increasing military support
increasing political support and now you
know talking about uh greater you know
economic uh
um collaboration but also uh the united
states brigading uh you know reinventing
the quad uh creating orcas you know all
of these things and and
you know um
[Music]
generally i think creating uh for for
china a sense of being uh boxed in and
you know and and put under pressure so
um
how does this
play out well the problem for the united
states is that taiwan forms a critical
part of the first island chain this
chain of islands runs along china's
eastern seaboard from japan through the
philippines to borneo
um and if that
island chain first island chain is
broken this fundamentally alters the
strategic balance in the indo-pacific
it doesn't mean that the united states
ceases to be a major power but it's
going to be in that situation a very
different power and effectively you know
no longer you know able to act
unconstrained in the western pacific
which it has been used to doing
um the chinese
leadership trope for some time has been
the easters rising the west is in
decline well events in ukraine have
perhaps suggested that the western
decline is you know perhaps less
precipitative than the chinese
leadership might think and in any case
this is not a zero-sum game you know it
is not a kind of net tran there there is
not you know a specific quantum of power
um transfer of some of which involves
necessarily a loss of an equal amount
somewhere else it doesn't work like that
um but the question you know the the
real issue is you know um
can we you know get to a situation where
the united states and china can back off
one of the biggest problems cindy
mentioned diplomacy i have never seen a
period since the depth of the cultural
revolution when communication between
china and the west has been less
and more contested and fraught than it
is at the moment
okay so so let's
come to the first theme to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you